Hi, welcome back. Today is my second
session on active versus passive
investing. If you remember in the last
session, we laid out the evidence that
active money management at least
collectively has underperformed. That
most active money managers underperform
the market. And that makes a case for
passive investing in index funds and
ETFs.
Now, if you get pushback from active
money managers, usually in the context
of, "Hey, the average might be bad, but
that's brought down by poor money
managers. Where are the good money
managers?" And that's some basis, right?
There's clearly a variation across money
managers. Maybe the average is brought
down by bad money managers who stay bad
and that the good managers actually beat
the market.
So, in this session, I want to focus on
the evidence on whether that's the case.
And I'm going to give away the final
finding. There's very little evidence at
least across time and across different
kinds of money managers of continuity of
good money managers staying good and bad
money managers staying bad.
There's some evidence of what's called a
hot hand phenomenon. We'll talk about
that. But it's passing. It's not
long-term. In the long-term, there's
very little evidence for the, you know,
for for the for the statement of the
argument at least that's the bad money
managers who are causing the problem and
the good money managers deliver value.
So, to see the easiest way of seeing
that there's no continuity is to do the
following. It's called a transition
probability.
And I'm going to show you how it's
computed using this data from 2022 to
2024.
Basically, at the start of every year,
you break
mutual funds down based on performance
from top quartile to bottom quartile.
Quartile one are the best.
And quartile four four are the worst.
So, you break money managers down. Then
you track what they do in the next year
or the next period, whatever that
period, and see what quartile they fall
in.
Uh
world in which the best money managers
stay the best, you should see the
transition probability for quartile one
to quartile one to be a very high
number, 40, 50, 60, in a perfect world,
100%. And bad money managers stay bad,
the quartile four managers will stay in
quartile four.
In this table, you can make your own
judgments, but 25% is randomness. That
would be if you had in any given year,
the reason you were in the top was the
core the bottom was pure luck.
Then the next year, you should have
about a 25% chance.
Let's take a look at some of the boxes
at least.
25.5% of the managers in the top
quartile stay in the top quartile.
Only 10.6% of the managers in the bottom
quartile stay in the bottom quartile,
but here's the catch. This study also
looked at what happens to some of the
funds that didn't make it. They get
merged or liquidated, and you can see
it's that number is not 0%.
Overall, if you look at these
statistics, there is very little
evidence of continuity. In fact, you
could argue that there's stronger
evidence of
dramatic shifts from one end of the
spectrum to another, that quartile one
stocks have a higher chance of ending
our quartile five one funds and have a
higher chance of ending in the very
bottom of the pile rather than the top
of the pile.
And there's intuitively reason for that,
right? If you're a high-risk money
manager, you go for big stakes, you
concentrate your portfolio. When you are
right, you will be at the top. When
you're wrong, you're going to be at the
bottom.
Now, to support investors in the face of
all of this bad mutual fund performance,
there have been services that have come
out that rank mutual funds. Perhaps what
the best known is Morningstar, which
gives mutual funds stars from five stars
if you're the very best to one star.
And uh there are there are people who
invest based on Morningstar ratings,
arguing that Morningstar ratings are
high, these are good funds.
This
fairly early study Morningstar ratings
looks at whether there's predictive
power in these ratings.
The highest performing funds actually
underperformed the market by about 1 and
1/2%.
The lowest performing funds clearly
underperformed the market by a lot more.
So, at a very generic level, there is
some information.
But as a investor, if I said, "Look, I'd
want to use this to pick funds." It's
very noisy information because outside
of that very lowest ranking funds, it's
very difficult to find a pattern here
that you can invest based on.
Now, Morningstar has revamped its
rankings over time trying to make them
better and it's it's made some
improvements. Instead of having four
large groups like it did prior to 2002,
now it's 48 smaller subgroups that these
stars are based on.
The risk measures are much more complete
now to capture the downside risk. And
then you have a fund with multiple
classes, it's consolidated as one fund
rather than be treated as separate
funds.
And they do have some predictive power,
at least this study, but it's it's mild.
The higher rated funds earn higher
returns than the lower rated funds.
But they often have higher fees as well
and that's and if you adjust for those
fees, it's unclear whether those higher
returns persist.
So, there's no persistence or no
continuity in rank in in performance and
the rank the the services that rank
mutual funds don't do that great a job
of separating the great from the good to
the average and the bad.
But here comes the one piece of evidence
with mutual funds that might be
interesting to investors.
And this is a something that was
uncovered about 20 or 25 years ago by
researchers. They discovered there was
this phenomenon of a hot hand. What does
that mean?
That winners stayed winners at least in
the near term. So, the way to read this
is this were truly random, the
percentage of repeat winners should be
50% and if you beat 50% by enough,
you're statistically deviating from
randomness. So, if you take a year like
where 74.4%
of winners from the previous year
repeated, you had clearly a violation of
randomness. That's a hot hand
phenomenon.
And that hot hand phenomenon persists
across both small and large funds. It's
not just the biggest funds or the
smallest funds, there seems to be
persistence. Persistence in what sense?
We look at the des- if you break down
these funds based on excess returns in
the prior year, they continue to earn
excess returns in the next year.
So, rather than use Morningstar ratings,
you could probably look at the
performance last year if you believe in
the hot hands phenomenon,
you're at least going to make higher
returns for the next year, but the hot
hands become much cooler if you extend
out the time period.
So, active money management's very
difficult to make a case for active
money management collectively, either in
the aggregate or even as individual
money managers. So, the question is why
do active money managers fail? Why with
all these resources
are they unable to beat the market?
I can I can point to five factors. First
is transactions costs. Very high
transactions costs and I'll show you the
evidence in transactions costs
and while active money managers have
become better at controlling
transactions costs, guess who they're
competing with? Index funds, which have
almost no transactions costs.
The second is and this cuts to the heart
of this class is I'm going to argue that
most active money managers have no core
investment philosophy.
They have strategies. They chase the
strategy that worked the best last year
and that means you're often shifting
your portfolio with higher transactions
costs, higher turnover.
Too much activity. In fact, you could
argue both the transactions costs and
too much activity come from having no
core core philosophy. You trade too
much.
And many of them try to time markets at
least implicitly by pulling money out of
equities, holding it in cash when they
think the market's going to go down.
And putting more money back in the
market when the market they think the
market's going to go up. They They're
just not great market timers.
And finally, there are behavioral issues
that come from how how they get
judged as active money managers. You're
saying, "What are you talking about?" If
you're a mutual fund manager, the way
you get judged is not against the market
or against what I would expect you to
make. It's against other mutual fund
managers
who practice your craft.
To emerge as a hero, then all you got to
do is be better than the rest of those
people you compete with, which leads I
think to a lot of herd mentality. Which
is doing what everybody else is doing
because you're less likely to get get
get yourself into trouble.
So, let's take those issues. Let's take
the transactions costs. You As I said,
now active money managers have become
better at controlling costs. If you take
active money managers for instance, a 1%
transaction cost at the end of the '90s
is now down to about 0.7%. That's good.
Transactions costs for active money
managers have dropped.
But guess who you're competing against?
Not other active money managers, but
passive investors whose transactions
costs have also dropped
down to close to zero.
So, on a transactions cost basis, that's
a
That's a barrier to beating the market
is this collective cost.
In fact, Bill Sharpe, long time ago,
made the argument that collectively
active money managers have to beat the
market. Have No, I have to underperform
the market because they collectively
have transactions costs,
which means it's going to be a drain on
their return.
Second is the more turnover you see in
in an actively run fund, the worse the
returns going to be. So, in this graph,
for instance,
we know you
funds were broken down from lowest
turnover ratios to highest turnover
reflecting how much they trade.
And the the first column is actually the
total return, right? Prior to
prior to adjusting for risk and
transaction. And then you look at the
excess returns and you can see that the
excess returns become more and more
negative the more you trade.
In fact, the trading cost, which is
basically reflection of the last graph,
the trading cost tend to rise and the
highest trading cost funds have a much
tougher time matching up to the market.
So, when you look at a fund rather than
look at Morningstar's Morningstar's
stars for the fund or even last year's
performance,
maybe the key variable you should look
at
is the trading cost number. If that
number is high,
history suggests you should avoid the
fund. The lower that number, the greater
the chance the fund has of actually
beating the market.
And a related issue, the more you trade,
the higher your tax burden. And we
talked about this in the context of tax
cost very early in this class.
If you look at the five largest index
funds and compare them to the 10 largest
active funds, the difference between
pre-tax and post-tax returns to
investors is much smaller in index
funds. You face a much smaller burden.
So, in addition to index funds kind of
doing better than active money managers
even before taxes, after taxes that
difference becomes even larger.
Second, as I said, there seems to be no
core philosophy. One of the ways you can
measure how much drift there is is,
you know, S&P uh, maintains this
database of
how funds drift from one style to
another. By looking at what they invest
in. So, if you say you're a large cap
fund and you start buying small cap
stocks, you you've drifted in style.
See the the pi- the pie chart in the
orange portion? That's the portion of
invest- of mutual fund managers who
drifted away from their starting
description. The only two groups where
managers for the most part stayed in
their lane in their original style is
emerging market funds. It's kind of
difficult to shift away from emerging
markets without giving away the game and
international small cap funds. In every
other grouping, more than 50% of fund
managers shifted away, did not stay
consistent with their original style.
We talked about too much activity. There
was a very interesting and a very
telling study about what activity does
to active money managers.
And what this study looked at is what
the returns on mutual funds would have
been if their portfolios had been frozen
in what they owned on January 1st of
each year compared to what they actually
generated with all the money managers
showing up every day and doing what they
did during the course of the year, all
that activity.
And it found that for the most part,
these funds would have been better off
leaving their portfolio untouched rather
than having all the activity that they
did during the course of the year.
Activity for the most part hurts money
managers and the more active you are,
the tougher it becomes to beat the
market.
As for the failure to stay invested, the
defense that equity fund managers will
give you is we're trying to time the
market. And in this graph, which looks
at six market downturns, we look at how
well active equity mutual fund managers
have done in protecting their clients
from downturns.
1987, it's true, active and perhaps
because it happened so quickly, active
fund managers did deliver a slightly
less negative return but in one, two,
three, four of the downturns
active money managers actually had more
negative returns during a downturn. So
if their sales pitch is, "We protect you
in the next downturn." It's history
suggests it's not happening.
One final factor and this is the
behavioral factors. There's a lack of
consistency issue. We talked about this
and that lack of consistency coming from
the fact that you don't have a core
philosophy means you have higher expense
ratios, more trading, higher taxes.
Lot of herd behavior. You're better off
as a fund manager doing what everybody
else is doing and even if you fail,
you're not going to lose your job
whereas if you're the outsider, the
contrarian doing something different and
you fail, you're more likely to be
fired.
There's a lot of window dressing. You
want to make yourself look good rather
than actually doing good.
So you see this towards the end of every
quarter where mutual fund managers get
rid of their losers and try to load up
on winners even though it's too late to
actually win on those winners. Lot of
window dressing.
So what's the bottom line? If you look
at the research on market
inefficiencies, it seems like there are
so many inefficiencies you can take
advantage of to beat the market. On
paper
it's easy to beat the market.
In practice though
when you look at professional money
managers who are using exactly those
same inefficiencies trying to exploit
them
it turns out much more difficult for
them. In fact, they underperform the
market. So the question is what is it
that's causing the slip between the cup
and the lip? And what you see on paper
and what gets delivered.
And I think it's a reflection of in
addition to transactions, costs, and
taxes which are very real issues. Even
if you bring them in, it's a reflection
of the fact that it's much more
difficult to execute many of these
strategies that look good on paper than
it looks on paper.
And that's part of the reason why the
right end game for many people in
markets might be to invest your money in
an index.
Incidentally, remember the greatest
value investor of all time, Warren
Buffett, gives exactly this advice to a
lot of people who come to the Berkshire
Hathaway meetings. He tells them, "Look,
if I were starting today, I'd probably
put more of my money or all of my money
in an index rather than do what I did
because the world has changed, the
market has changed."
It's a testimonial to how much more
difficult it's become to win at the
active investing game.
If you're an active investor, I hope I
haven't depressed you too much, but the
way I would describe this is this is a
very tough game to win. And if you
embark on beating the market,
recognize that the odds are against you,
and you've got to work really hard,
create a competitive advantage that
actually stays sustained to beat the
market. I hope you pull it off.
And I hope you found this session
useful.
Thank you very much for listening.